personne ne mange des hot dogs en
s'imaginant que c'est un aliment santé
depuis près de 20 ans les études sonne
l'alarmé sur le lien entre des viandes
transformées et le cancer organisation
mondiale de la santé vient de passer au
peigne fin plus de 800 études sur le
sujet et a classé les charcuteries dans
la catégorie des agents cancérigènes
qu'on catégorise maintenant les
charcuteries comme étant associée à une
augmentation du risque de cancer chez du
meca sergent une chaîne humaine ce site
a pas encore établi jambons saucisses
béthune bref le patrimoine alimentaire
québécois est au banc des accusés un
facteur de risque d'augmentation d'un
tueur très important canado qu'est le
cancer colorectal
on estime que 34 mille décès par année
dans le monde sont attribuables une
alimentation riche en charcuterie l' oms
rapporte une consommation quotidienne de
50 g de charcuteries l'équivalent de
deux saucisses augmente les risques de
cancer colorectal de 18%
les nombreux agents de conservation
comme les nitrites sont en partie à
blâmer les amateurs de dogues doivent
modérer leur consommation
je gérais mais c'est sûr que si on a
trop bien trop hot six comme la
modération son amant schtroumpfs c'est
ce que prétend un moment donné ça c'est
pour les bons plans sorties le premier
toit par cancer au canada c'est le cas
c'est du pur 90% des cancers du poumon
c'est le tableau les deux génial c'est
le cas de recaler on estime que 85 % des
cancers du côlon et du rectum sont
associés aux modes de vie l hygiène de
vie
quand on identifie un facteur qui est
associée à une réduction du risque de
cancer colorectal c'est pas n'importe
quoi la viande rouge et même la viande
de porc sont aussi montrés du doigt et
classé comme potentiellement
cancérigènes
les végétariens ne devraient pas se
réjouir trop vite puisque l' oms ne
recommande pas pour autant les régimes
sans viande qui comporte parfois des
carences en protéines le cancer n'est
jamais à prendre à la légère mais il
faut souvent tenir compte de plusieurs
facteurs et se rappeler que l'alcool le
tabac et la sédentarité
tu es fini en plus de gens que redog
casio neil ici une chaîne marsolais
radio canada montréal